VA who you are going to vote for next Sunday,
July 23rd.
baby I don't vote
the baby why the baby
because it is the one that most
aligns with my thoughts
what do you like about the popular party
for
to see
yes Pedro Sanchez no yes
but what do you like about the popular party
I don't know so much about politics either
what has most affected the good of my family I believe
and you believe that there will be options for
kick the government out of action
yes yes yes I believe
I think so
and that if the popular party does not have an absolute majority
with whom do you think he will want to make a pact
with Vox and what do you think of Vox
1 bit extremist in some ideas but
in some others well
so it seems to me that he has clear ideas
which still
the baby should get wetter
tell me one you like
I don't know,
so everything about immigration.
all that is Vox
Vox is very,
very hard on your ideas about
immigrants and all that
and the PP is more Pacific there,
so to speak.
do you like these Vox ideas
yes good some